le propriétaire du Monster Gazette post
média network de Toronto supprime une
dizaine de postes dans la salle de
rédaction c'est un parc d'histoire de
Montréal qui risque de sombrer depuis
très longtemps il fait partie du paysage
montréalais ce quotidien a été fondé en
1778 par Fleury Mesplet un imprimeur
français
à cause de ces à cause de ses idées
après son emprisonnement de 3 ans et
quelques mois il y aura encore le
courage de publier le journal dont vous
faites mention la Gazette de Montréal
qui est l'ancêtre effectivement de du
journal du quotidien d'aujourd'hui au
début le journal était publié en
français et en anglais
le seul concurrent sérieux qui a eu la
Gazette c'est le Monster
qui a fermé ses portes en 1979 depuis la
Gazette est devenue le porte-voix de la
communauté anglophone de Montréal
les amis de la Gazette viennent de
lancer une pétition pour sauver le
journal une pétition qui a récolté
jusqu'à maintenant 3000 noms Joss freed
et chroniqueur à La Gazette depuis 35
ans et souhaite une intervention
gouvernementale pour assurer la survie
du quotidien anglophone le père serait
pas seulement une perte pour le comité
anglophone mais je pense pour toute la
société québécoise c'est un voix
présente mais aussi historique dans
l'histoire de Québec un espoir peut-être
l'homme d'affaires Mitch Garber c'est du
prêt à acheter le journal mais pour
l'instant en tout cas aucune négociation
n'est en cours entre le propriétaire
actuel du quotidien et l'homme
d'affaires ici Jacques bissonner
Radio-Canada MONT